alors que le coe vide 19 semblait
presque éradiquée sur le sol chinois
le pays reste sous la menace d'une
deuxième vague
au total ce week-end 75 nouveaux cas ont
été dénombrés
rien qu'à pékin mis en cause le marché
de gros de xyntha dit l'un des plus
importants de la région dans le sud de
la capitale
très surveillé selon les autorités ce
marché qui va en poissons viandes et
légumes serait le foyer de la vague de
contamination qui préoccupe les
autorités
les médias officiels ont notamment
rapporté que le virus avait été détecté
sur des planches servant à découper du
saumon emporté une information
inquiétante quand on sait que le marché
de green fadi fourni plus de 80 % des
restaurants de pékin mais l'information
ne semble pas inquiéter les pékinois qui
reste plutôt serein je pense que la
probabilité qu'il y ait une épidémie
majeure est faible d'un millier de
personnes tout au plus c'est mon avis
personnel parce qu'il est facile de vous
retrouver grâce aux données du
gouvernement
pékin dispose de suffisamment de
ressources médicales je ne pense pas que
ce soit au site et kahone
il y a eu de la panique lors de la
première vague mais pour la deuxième
vague
il n'y a pas lieu de s'inquiéter nous
avons les données
le gouvernement contrôle les choses
strictement la population est vigilante
il ne devrait pas y avoir de problème il
n'y a pas de raison de paniquer je pense
qu'ici ça va après tout c'est très loin
tous ces gens vont être testés alors ça
va en plus le flux de personnes est
limitée ici donc je ne suis pas très
inquiète
cette découverte a donc entraîné le
confinement de vente et une zone
résidentielle
entre dimanche et lundi face à cette
agitation
la ville a également annoncé pour cette
semaine une campagne massive de
dépistage à laquelle ont déjà été soumis
2000 employés du marché quant aux
autorités sanitaires
elles ont ordonné une campagne
d'inspection dans toute la ville et les
responsables de pékin ne compte pas
s'arrêter là
ils se disent prêts à retracer
le parcours d'environ 200000 personnes
qui auraient visité le marché
nous avons organisé des activités de
porte-à-porte cela signifie que nous
allons rendre visite aux gens qui sont
allés au marché les appeler au téléphone
ou bien les contacter par messagerie
s'ils sont testés positifs ils seront
placés en quarantaine
à noter par ailleurs que la chine et
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
travaille toujours en étroite
collaboration
malgré les nombreuses critiques
internationales sur la gestion de la
crise ducobu de 19